ils étaient près de 150 agents à s'être
rassemblés devant la mairie de maurepas
aujourd'hui le personnel municipal
répondait à l'appel des syndicats cfdt
et unsa
trop de souffrance au travail ça va pas
de part et d'autre de tous les agences
et c'est toujours la même chose qui
ressort c'est on n'a pas assez de
matériel pour travailler on n'a pas
assez de moyens humains pour travailler
si on aurait pu éviter voilà mais bon
malheureusement on en est là et c'est
dommage on est uniquement sur une
gestion financière et c'est un peu le
reproche qu'on fait je veux dire on peut
pas être assimilée effective
bon c'est le tract on est un agent égale
un pion c'est ça je veux dire non on
n'est pas que des que quand un budget à
la fin de l'année en fait c'est ça le
truc c'est que cette gestion est laid
que financières ça manque d'humanité
très franchement le mouvement inhabituel
sur la commune est soutenu par les élus
de l'opposition se fait plus de 35 ans
qui en a pas eu de grève à l'appel des
agents de la mairie pour des affaires de
la mairie
il ya eu et ponctuellement des
participations à des grèves nationales
ça ça existait mais de mémoire d'élu je
n'ai jamais vu ça ça veut dire que qu'il
ya beaucoup de problèmes en interne
ce que l'on sait art par des mots que
l'on entend ici ou là par des
indiscrétions puisque les gens ne
peuvent pas parler
c'est une situation qui dure depuis
plusieurs mois donc pourquoi dire
presque un an où nous avons des
témoignages d'un certain nombre d'agents
qui nous font part de leurs difficultés
humaines a travaillé depuis quelques
temps et ça ça nous touche fortement en
tant qu'être humain la majorité elle
souligne son incompréhension devant le
manque de revendications et avance le
contexte national avec la baisse des
dotations aux collectivités de 2,4
millions d'euros pour la commune je vais
pas m'étaler mais en tout cas nous avons
découvert des situations complexes que
nous traitons mais comme je les dis j'ai
mis en place depuis que je suis arrivé
responsabilité au moins une réunion par
trimestre avec les partenaires sociaux
ce qui n'existait pas avant
et j'ai moi-même vous souhaitez
également des rendez-vous direct dans
les services donc par service avec les
agents pour tout se dire elle les
représentants syndicaux ont été reçus
dans l'après midi par le maire grégory
gars restiez la commune emploie 600
agents dont 150 vacataires un tiers du
personnel étaient en grève aujourd'hui
selon les syndicats 1 car selon la
municipalité